こんにちははじめシャツはです僕たち ga 社とか車とか
ドリームのに取るわけでそれぞれに共通していることは何か
そう車輪が付いている俺たちはね車輪の付いたね4芸者とかドリームをとかに乗って
日々生活を送ってるわけなんですけども我々人間も売り物になれないことを重ねたわけ
です
で今回はほとんど社員どうぞよじゃあこれ
以前沿って全便です今回はこちらの車輪様は事前に僕の身体に付けますちゃんと人間が
ねその車とが乗りボードになることを言って普段の何ライブの移動速度で移動すること
ができてこれから自動車もね自転車も必要のないえっこんな世界余興ネジっちゃう女が
作ってみようと思います別降臨から行くかどうつければいいんだろうねペンギンは普通
にぼ
この大豆に言うんですけども郷林はちょっと物ねそうなんで普通の裏につけますこう
いう感じでしっかりここで走れるようにします
天才電話では自分でもね今回起きたと思うか考え捉えて本買いに感謝もじゃないですか
いそうでしょ
未来が見えるものには全然部位がこれを履いてるのが俺には想像できる
みんな国道ねこれでねなんか四つん這いで見なかったよ
いやー最も s くそーぞう入ってるは聴けそうじゃない願いその問題出さ
これにこうつければだろこれあああ
これ術てるでしょ2 way easy
アブていたそうな帰らずなくらいきんにくんあれやった方ない
こういう
ソーラー好きな金とれるん
どうする乳首とかですよっそうあげちゃうんです
マジってのこうやってやっぱり怖い怖いこれまで履けないんだけど
さああああ
あっ浜で足つった ok 車輪が4つ入ったので早速ちょっとね
動いてみようと思いますよ用車で伝えればそれでも勝つ
ていた
ブーバーっっ
めっちゃは者茶っ葉
勢いで言ってず29誰なんだックリアできるか
はぁっ
32うわぁ
jr
本当に無理今回ぷ
goo
いません
無理でしたああっちょっと動画の趣旨が変わっちゃうんですけども動くこたつの机を
作ってみようと思いますこれで機は許してくれるよねみた
きたそうえっ
ほらなんかグリーは芝居するは5位
あん
あああああっん
はっはっは